in this video we'll be looking at the
complete history of Indiana Jones from
the first four films the television
series novels and Comics some of this
may be changed later on as we learn more
from Indiana Jones in the dial of
Destiny but for now this is everything
we know about Indiana Jones starting
with his birth on July 1 1899 in
Princeton New Jersey his father Henry
Jones senior was a professor of medieval
studies and a strict disciplinarian who
taught him several languages and
instilled in him a love of history and
Archeology his mother Anna Jones was a
loving and supportive woman who
encouraged his curiosity and Imagination
but she died of scarlet fever when he
was just nine years old although his
birth name was Henry Walton Jones Jr he
got the nickname Indiana from his pet
dog who was also his best friend he
later adopted it as his professional
name when he became an archaeologist
Jones had a nomadic childhood traveling
around the world with his parents and
his tutor miss Helen Seymour he visited
many countries and met many famous
historical figures such as Theodore
Roosevelt Leo Tolstoy Thomas Edison
Pablo Picasso Winston Churchill and
Albert Schweitzer he also had many
adventures and learned many skills such
as horse riding fencing flying planes
playing the saxophone and speaking
several languages he developed a passion
for archeology and a sense of justice
often getting into conflicts and
Mysteries that challenged his wits and
courage in these younger years were
featured in the television series The
Young Adventures of Indiana Jones which
aired from 1992 to 1996. it depicts the
teenage and young adult years of Indiana
Jones from 1916 to 1920. the series
shows how Indiana fought in World War
one under various aliases such as Henry
defense and Captain Dynamite he served
in the Belgian Army the French Army and
the U.S Army intelligence he also worked
as a spy for various countries and
organizations the series also shows how
Indiana Jones studied archeology at the
University of Chicago under Professor
Abner Ravenwood who became his mentor
and friend he later transferred to
France where he earned an undergraduate
degree in linguistics the series also
shows how Indiana Jones had many
romantic relationships with different
women such as Vicky Prentiss Mata Hari
Nancy stratomire Deidra Campbell whom he
married briefly Marion Ravenwood
ravenwood's daughter Willie Scott a
singer Elsa Schneider a Nazi spy Molly
Walder his fiancee who died in a plane
crash a Amy Wharton a journalist Claire
Lieberman a filmmaker Emily a Belgian
nurse Sophie a French princess and
others he also had two children Henry
Walton Mutt Williams Jones III with
Marion and Sophie Jones with Emily
although she's only mentioned a couple
of times and may have been retconned by
later titles the first four films of the
Indiana Jones franchise are Raiders of
the Lost Ark Indiana Jones and the
Temple of Doom Indiana Jones and the
Last Crusade and Indiana Jones in the
Kingdom of the Crystal Skull the first
three are set in the 1930s and the last
in the 1950s and they feature Harrison
Ford playing Indiana Jones in Raiders of
the Lost Ark India is hired by the US
government to find the Ark of the
Covenant before the Nazis do he teams up
with Marion Ravenwood his former lover
and Salah his Egyptian friend to locate
the ancient artifact in Egypt along the
way he faces many dangers and enemies
such as snakes booby traps a rival
archaeologist Renee belock Nazi agent
Arnold Toad and gestapo officer Dietrich
he manages to recover the ark but loses
it to the Nazis again he follows them to
an island where they plan to open it and
harness its power he Witnesses the wrath
of God as the ark unleashes a deadly
force that kills all the Nazis he and
Marion Survive by closing their eyes and
not looking at the ark they returned to
the U.S where the ark is stored and a
secret Warehouse by the government and
Indiana Jones and the Temple of Doom
Indie escapes from a deal gone wrong
with a Chinese gangster named Lao Shay
in Shanghai he along with his sidekick
Short Round And Willie Scott a singer
and his love interest born a plane that
belongs to Lao Shay they're forced to
jump out of the plane when the pilot
sabotage and crash it into the Himalayas
they end up in a small village in India
where they learn that a cult led by mola
Ram has stolen a sacred stone and
kidnapped the children of the villagers
they agree to help the villagers and
travel to Bangkok Palace where they
discover a secret passage to an
underground Temple there they witnessed
the cult performing human sacrifices and
using enslaved children to mine for more
Stones they're captured by the cult and
tortured but managed to escape with the
help of Short Round they fight their way
out of the temple rescue the children
and retrieve the stone they returned to
the village where they're welcomed as
heroes in Indiana Jones in the Last
Crusade India is contacted by Walter
Donovan a wealthy businessman who
informs him that his father Henry Jones
senior has gone missing while searching
for the Holy Grail the cup that Jesus
used at the Last Supper he also shows
him a partial inscription of a knight's
Tombstone that reveals the location of
the Grail Indiana Jones travels to
Venice where he meets with Dr Elsa
Schneider an Austrian art historian and
Nazi spy who is working with his father
they find the tombstone under a library
and decipher the rest of the inscription
they're attacked by members of a secret
society called the Brotherhood of the
cruciform sword who are sworn to protect
the Grail from falling into evil hands
the escape and follow Henry's Trail to
Castle brunwald on the Austrian German
border where they find him held captive
by Nazis led by Colonel focal they
rescue him and flee on a motorcycle but
are pursued by Nazis and tanks they
reach a zeppelin where they board it and
fly away however they discover that
Donovan and Elsa are also on board and
working with the Nazis they escape on a
biplane and fly to Turkey where they
meet Salah their old friend who guides
them to the canyon of the Crescent Moon
where the Grail is hidden there they
encounter three booby traps that test
their faith wisdom and humility they
also face Donovan Elsa Fogle and their
Nazi troops who have followed them
Donovan shoots Henry to force Indiana to
find the grill and use its healing
powers to save him Indiana succeeds in
finding the true Grill among many false
ones but is worn by an ancient Knight
who guards it that it cannot be taken
beyond the temple Elsa tries to take the
Grail but causes the temple to collapse
she falls into a Chasm while trying to
reach the Grail and Indiana almost does
the same but is saved by his father they
escape the temple with Salah in the
night who bids them farewell and they
ride into the sunset having completed
their quest in Indiana Jones in the
Kingdom of the Crystal Skull which takes
place in 1957. India is kidnapped by
Soviet agents led by Iran smallko they
force him to help them find the Crystal
Skull of akator a powerful artifact that
is said to contain the knowledge of the
Ancients Jones escapes and teams up with
his former lover Marion Ravenwood and
their son Mutt Williams to find the
skull before the Soviets do the trio
travels to Peru where they meet up with
Professor Harold Oxley an expert on the
crystal skulls Oxley has gone mad but
he's able to tell Jones that the skull
is located in the lost city of akator
the Soviets also reach akator and a
battle ensues between Jones's group and
the Soviets in the end Jones is able to
recover the Crystal Skull and use it to
defeat spalko the film ends with Jones
and his friends returning to the United
States where they're hailed as Heroes
the comics and novels of Indiana Jones
expand on adventures and fill in the
gaps between the films they're
considered part of the official Canon of
the franchise although some of them may
contradict each other or the films the
comics were published by Marvel comics
from 1981 to 1986 and by Dark Horse
Comics from 1991 to 2009 they feature
stories set before during and after the
events of the films as well as Original
Stories That explore different aspects
of Indiana Jones character and history
including encounters with Nazis who are
able to control the weather and Lawrence
of Arabia some of the notable Comics
include Indiana Jones in the fate of
Atlantis which is a classic story that
was originally adapted from the popular
video game of the same name in the comic
Indy travels to the lost city of
Atlantis in search of a powerful
artifact that could be used for good or
evil along the way he battles Nazis sea
monsters and even the gods themselves
another is Indiana Jones Thunder in the
orient this is a more recent story that
takes Indy to Asia in search of Buddha's
original writings along the way he
battles Japanese soldiers monks and even
a dragon another is Indiana Jones and
the Spear of Destiny this story sees
Indy travel to Berlin in 1945 to recover
the Spear of Destiny a powerful relic of
Nazis believe can give them victory in
the war Andy must Race Against Time to
stop the Nazis from getting their hands
on the spear and he must also contend
with a supernatural Force that's
protecting the spear lastly there's
Indiana Jones and the Golden Fleece
which is a story that takes Indy to
Greece in search of the Golden Fleece a
legendary artifact that's said to Grant
immortality along the way he battles a
group of Bandits a cyclops and even the
Minotaur the novels were published by
Banton books from 1984 to 1999 and my
Ballentine books from 2008 to 2009. they
also feature stories set before during
and after the events of the films as
well as some original stories that
introduced new characters and villains
some of the notable novels include
Indiana Jones and the Peril Delphi which
sees Indy travel to Delphi Greece in
search of another powerful artifact that
can grant immortality along the way he
battles a group of cultists a Seder and
even the delphic Oracle herself another
novel is Indiana Jones and the dance of
the Giants which takes Indy to England
in search of the legendary Wizard Merlin
along the way he again battles a group
of Nazis a giant and a dragon another
story is Indiana Jones and the secret of
the Sphinx which sees their
archaeologists travel to Egypt in search
of the Omega book a mystical text that
contains the history and fate of every
human being it's no surprise that he
again encounters a group of terrorists
and even a mummy lastly there's Indiana
Jones in the hollow Earth which takes
Andy to the Center of the Earth in
search of A Lost Civilization and this
story encounters a group of cavemen a
giant squid and a giant volcano we see
Indiana Jones in his much older years
and the young adventures of Indiana
Jones TV series as a framing device he's
portrayed by George Hall as a 93 year
old man living in New York City in 1993.
he has an eye patch over his right eye
which he lost in an unspecified incident
he often recounts his past Adventures to
various people he meets such as Indy
Walton Juniors IV his grandson a Russian
documentarian named Irina spalco a
reference to the villain of Indiana
Jones and the kingdom of the Crystal
Skull a jazz musician named Sydney besha
and others this old version of Indy was
originally intended to be part of a
spin-off TV series called The Adventures
of Young Indiana Jones mystery of the
Blues which would have focused on his
later years as an archaeologist and
Professor however this project was never
realized and only one episode was
produced which aired as part of the
young Adventure of Indiana Jones TV
series in 1993. subscribe for more Star
Wars Marvel and Indiana Jones content
and check out the video on your screen
too
[Music]